[Music]
Jana Jana Fournier you guys are all
parents what would your reaction be what
do you think will be if your kids come
to you and say this is what I want to do
I want to Korean entertainment oh oh I'm
just gonna make sure that it's done the
right way cuz there's definitely a right
and wrong way to do it and I'm not the
dad that's pushing them towards anything
like don't you want to sing say I'm not
that guy you know if he chooses it I'm
gonna be there to support him and make
sure that everything is done the right
way and that he's focused on it for real
and not you know distracted by the
multiple distractions that are there
yeah I'm just let him ride with it yeah
I think for me I just I know that if
they're real artists if they are artists
there's nothing I can do to stop em
which I wouldn't want to anyway if I we
just want to support them and Erin just
you know give them all the knowledge
that I had an experience you know
they've been around this since they were
born with me and their dad I don't think
it's even interested I always have the
support of my parents that was do what
you love follow your passions I always
say it would do that with Joey but we do
have wrong joke really this would keep
her out of it is this like we actually
righteously think of things that'll be
like if she does I didn't come if she's
a grew up around this you know like
going going through all this is very
normal but how funny would it be for
your daughter did not have rhythm
what's my you know what pushing her in
the tutu in there no I was made to
gymnastic yeah
[Music]
you